we're looking at a parametric's question
I put it on the screen I realized that
it's a bit hard to see there really I'm
gonna do two questions but really one is
just a subset of the other
so here's the question I'm looking at
number two prove that the tangent at any
arbitrary point P on the proline is
equally inclined to the axis umbrella
and the focal cord through P rouser
okay now I'm just gonna say up front I'm
gonna do question three as well
question three looks terrible like you
just get overwhelmed by the number of
words right
as it happens once you do to three pops
out you just do one a single
construction and then it just it just
pops out so I'm gonna do three for the
two of the value of one okay three
actually is much easier than you think
once you sift through the language okay
- is really where the business end is
okay now if you did not attempt this
question then um then go ahead and
attempt it maybe later okay
and give it a real shot and then come
back and watch if you're running up
against the brick wall if you have given
it a shot
but I haven't trouble with it then I
highly recommend that you pay attention
okay so this really depends on how
you're feeling with your parametric's
whether you want to watch or whether you
want to just keep on going with your
critical values okay so just so I can
get a rough idea and they're gonna be
like mentally who's gonna try and pay
attention Spanish discussion yeah mostly
all right hands down
you'll need a parabola you'll need a
parabola because um the lion's share of
our thought here is going to be
geometric thought as parametric's often
is and we're gonna do a lot of work just
to understand what is going on and then
I'm gonna not really give you like
therefore most of the formal working
that is I will give you some okay but
the key thing I think is do you
understand the shape of what's happening
and how to logic your way through it so
step by step prove that the tangent at
any arbitrary point P on the parabola
stop so I have a parabola right you'll
notice they say the parabola the
parabola generally speaking you can get
a question like this a well-behaved
question
we'll just say to you the parabola x
squared equals 4a 1 in this context
having not been told that I mean I mean
parametric well it's not an unfair
conclusion to draw if it were sideways
parabola I just swapped everything with
an excellent wise if I was translated
some way you know I just translate calls
up the coordinates so when there's no
geometric arguments don't depend on that
I'll be fine
so I'm just gonna consider an x squared
equals 4 in one an arbitrary points any
way you like volunteer right so I'm
gonna place mine somewhere about then
there's my point P and I need a pirata
I need a tangent through that point okay
so you um grab your ruler
there is my tangent at any arbitrary
point P okay so far so good
what do we actually try to prove it has
something to do with angles
what's the key word that tells me that
clued me into the fact it's about angles
it's an uncommon worth it's worth in a
client right equally inclined that takes
a bit of thinking right but the only
other place that we know where we see
this word is angles of inclination right
that angles of inclination are very
specific if you've got a person I'm
looking at look at a flag right the
angle the inclination is okay I'm
looking up and I measure from the
horizontal okay that's the that's the
context we're used to using this in
right so you've got some kind of
important line and then you measure
what's the angle up to some object so
they've given us all of the objects that
we need
you've got the tangent and we want to be
equally inclined to number one the axis
of the parabola conveniently I already
have the answers of my brother joining
where is it the axis of the parabola for
this parabola is the y-axis you okay
with that so here comes the tangent and
it hits the axis here so this is the
angle that tells me how inclined I am
how the tangent is inclined to the axis
does that make sense okay so there's the
axis and that is how much the tangent is
inclined to the axis so if I so good
okay what's the other thing I'm inclined
to from the tangent again to the focal
chord through P okay so here's P just
approximately I would guess that the
view
the focal point is somewhere like there
let's call that yes okay and I have a
single cord that passes through P and
also passes through the focus so there's
my focal point now where is the angle
that tells me how the tangent is
inclined to that focal point where is it
now be careful right I here is the
tangent inclines the axis right so the
tangent incline to the focal chord looks
to me like this angle do you agree with
that vocal chord tangent one of the
advantages as me having done this sum
this diagram like it's knowing you to
scale but it's to scale enough that I'm
like look it's an acute angle where else
is the only other unit like I mean the
other option is this guy over here it's
clearly not angle it doesn't make sense
on my own in my geometry okay so I'm
trying to prove that I mean I marked
them in as equal which is a bit more D
right that's what I'm trying to prove so
the question is well what choice do I
have in my disposal I want to show that
that's it couldn't that now just don't
shout out an answer if you see it
immediately okay you need to think about
well what tools do I have to say work
out say this angle here okay off of
there well I know from my arm I know
from my M equals 10 theta just doing
normal like gradient I can work out that
angle based on this gradient and the
gradient this line not too hard to work
now I can work at that angle which means
I could work out this angle that would
be okay right those are going to be
related to each other how are they
related bundling how are they related
this guy in this guy
they are complimentary do you see why
they're complimentary just let me
quickly show you why I've got vertically
opposite here right there okay there's
the one sorry it is the x axis is the y
axis so I have a right angle in here so
I have a right angle this angle
listening these two have to add too many
did you carry that so I could use any
good standing even find my mass and then
take the compliment that'll give me that
Google but then I have to do this angle
somehow I have to calculate what it is
and I don't really have like I mean
gross I'm off at an angle that's kind of
the problem right the reason why the
axis is the EZ Egger work is because um
it's funny so that that's why you get
complementary stuff but here I've got
this at an angle and I have this
animated course like even if you find
out what this angle is you didn't have
to find out what this comes down to
access what that angle is then you have
to subtract them you're gonna get a
neighbor's back 10 inverse of that it's
gonna be a disaster
okay I reject that as a pathway to go to
this question what else could I do
has anyone seen something yet say it
again
okay so when you look right I tried to
avoid it by throwing away the focal
point but do you see the two angles I'm
interested in they reside in a single
triangle right do you see nothing like
that that line there if you don't see it
immediately it's like well how do I put
it
but now that's there you can't unsee it
okay now if it's true that those are the
case I should be on a pursue through
some other means that this side and this
side are equal should be able to like
like the question is telling me the
angles in either so therefore they're
telling me this is an isosceles triangle
you okay with that
like I don't actually know this yet I've
improved it but I'm trying to try and
map out how bad units now distances
distances I do okay because think about
this right this triangle is very
well-defined I know where everything in
this triangle is let's start with the
easy stuff what are the coordinates of
peak easy
yes even easier what's the definition of
s0 on a right now this point down here
it's a little bit harder to work out but
not that much you remember that the
equations for all of the different lines
in a parametric that you can't assume
them okay but let's just quickly work
out to find here now obviously it
depends on this tangent right so it's
just quickly rehearse how do you prove
the equation of the tangent okay you
know the point passes through by
definition you do know it's gradient so
I'm going to write what what for am I
going to use point grading form right so
he's my tangent at P changes okay I'm
gonna go Y minus y1 which is making
square equals M the gradient which is
pay by definition outside of X minus x1
which is C do any pain okay this is easy
it's 100 times right this is why minus a
P squared there's P X minus 2 AP squared
like you see people like you get to
memorize and that's a bit of pain but
like it's it's they're very easy to work
out add to both sides and that gives you
that and you like oh yeah that's the
feel respective possible good how do I
use that
so find this it's in MX those people
these are in expose people services
right you just read off - a piece where
that's the intercept down